I know that there are some in my
audience who say Joe Biden should pack
the court by packing the court we mean
adding seats to the Supreme Court such
that if you expand the court say from 9
to 13 seats by adding four and then
immediately select those four Supreme
Court Justices you could take control of
the court in the sense that by adding
four liberal justices you then take
control back I love the idea of taking
control back the problem I see
is that it really is opening the door to
Republicans doing the same the next time
they have a president in the white house
and then Democrats doing the same and
next thing you know we've got 17 19 21
23 seats it doesn't seem to me like
really the path forward just because
Biden can get away with it right now now
if Biden did it and we got a more
liberal Supreme Court and we got some
good decisions would I complain of
course I wouldn't complain